hi I'm Ann time carpet and I'm from
something about junior high school in
Illinois like to tell you about some
things no if you had to travel to
Palantine really is just American
suburbia not much to do but there is a
park aquatic center and all all these
sorts of things no actually in chicago
have several excellent quality museums
and like to feel a museum in the lake
shores and also historical areas like
park nearby green green actually means
to be environmentally responsible make
sure you use your clients resources in
accordance with future generations to me
you know it really is also those simple
things like maybe living in a shack or
something like that or maybe just a
smaller house rather known to make a
McMansion in equal bill nowadays we were
just using conserving energy but
sometimes you know these Cardinals
vaulted extravagant American lifestyle
and health care all things so we prize
and though they treat place or any
famous explorer world leader probably be
king of Todd I mean he just tracked
crowd just superior intelligence and
numbers and abilities was hit and run
tactics and he made magic conqueror of
all of Asian Europe for having to turn
Mac and I you know want to say you
conquered Europe oh no don't leave me
free to get to travel anymore on this
world you mean on this world can they go
off and you know I'd like to explore
some new bodies in the outer solar
system maybe that Titan or maybe Pluto
maybe two I seeker to build all your
call Sedna which is a mysterious very
edgy disorder and goes off how they just
do some exploration like any good
geologist and exploring and learning
more about the world and it's just
really interested in this redness
you know alkylene oh how i smoosh this
stuff into my brain is just so
interesting maybe all the stuff that
isn't there about 70 s movies or
football players or maybe just social
interaction is probably used for
devotion AR the city geography to put me
in charge your see the entire day first
two issues at your tackle is 11 space
exploration into global warming this
exploration is really an important part
of our daily exist our continued
existence as life-forms you know if you
want to stay here and be alive we better
get off this planet I mean if we ruin
their by global warming or maybe just
ask aaron asteroid slammed into us will
be toast we can't really stay in the
cradle forever it still helps keep on it
really need to go up explore other solar
systems and other our parts of our solar
system and just make sure we have a
continued existence of our parallelism
and global warming really the first
problem is people really denying it I'm
not saying that I can't see it but I
understand you're flawed no scientific
evidence and rather mistaken too we know
that global warming is a real problem
hope you know that and it's caused me to
be hungry as stated before and youre
doosan fight mental and footprint to
make sure we have a resource and Stan
earth and it may be may be a safety
button you go out on other planets so
it's really important that we can take
care of our earth and not just wasted
two ruins like and just expect 100 years
like some others whether they should
call it you know let's see if they know
well the sleep palm river is it starting
here his sources in Guinea and it on
well a saint paul river in water water
everywhere of course would be category
instead and starting getting it marks a
guinea liberia border for well several
hundred collaborate until mpz in the
Gulf of ganea its name because of the
fact of the Portuguese explorer first
thought named it saw I'm going to st.
Paul's day that's why I named after the
st. Paul
Deborah thank you and farewell
you